there's a cohort of people who are
scared about Ai and all the AI safety
stuff but then there's another kind of
very far extreme of just like accelerate
without thinking at all about downsides
Etc how do you balance these two things
I understand why people might be
apprehensive at the same time I think if
you look through the history of
Technology there have always been these
factions of people that are like oh no
like this new technology electricity or
whatever is dangerous it's like yes you
can electrocute yourself if you don't
use it the right way but it like it's
unquestionably the it you know moves the
world forward in meaningful ways we do
think about AI as like a great
technology it's going to move the world
forward in meaningful ways we're already
starting to see that I'm really excited
about future waves of innovation powered
by Ai and what you know what net new
experiences that we can't even conceive
of yet
today all right guys bang bang I've got
Peter here uh Peter you're at M12
Microsoft's Venture arm open AI absolute
chaos controversy uncertainty for an
entire week and every single person in
Tech was like buried with their nose in
their phone what is going on in your
head or m12s uh kind of internal
Communications when all the chaos is
happening like are you guys freaking out
or is it cool Comon collected the whole
time uh you know we TR we try to keep a
cool uh head about these things
generally speaking I will say just for
the in the interest of transparency and
disclosure M2 so we are Microsoft
Venture arm we did not actually do the
direct investment in open AI just for
the sake of clarity uh micros soft the
parent company invested in that and so I
you know I'm not privy to the all the
details of that Arrangement um suffices
to say I think we're happy kind of where
it netted out um you know I mean saa's
comments he he talked about it publicly
we're very encouraged by kind of how
things landed and how it was navigated I
know it was a little probably a little
touch and go who knows um but I think
overall um you know we have a lot of
confidence in open AI we have a great
relationship there and then from the M12
perspective uh specifically like we also
have a a good relationship with open AI
so we actually collaborate with them
from time to time um in fact recently
not that long ago about 30 of our
portfolio companies had like a day on
site with open AI um walking through
their latest technology you know some
Hands-On kind of keyboard engineering uh
that goes co-engineering it was a really
productive sort of collaboration session
so we do so that that type of stuff and
provide kind of that level of access to
the extent of um we can for our
portfolio companies kind of the uh you
know membership has its privileges so to
speak um with the in the M12 portfolio
so um you know big fans of open AI
generally and hope things continue to go
well now as you mentioned uh you guys
may not have made the direct investment
in open AI but you have made an
investment in a plethora of other
artificial intelligence uh startups talk
a little bit in terms of a corporate
Venture Capital firm uh how much of the
investment decisions is like I want to
make money versus I'm trying to do
something that's in the best interest of
Microsoft or give them an edge in the
market
it's a it's a really good question
because I think there are as many
flavors of corporate venture capital or
CVC as there are probably corporations
that do it um and you mentioned the kind
of strategic versus Financial Spectrum
we're actually evaluated on both metrics
which I think is uh I think makes sense
frankly it aligns incentives in an
interesting way so we're evaluated on
financial returns we have to make money
our leadership is quite clear about that
uh and then on the other hand we're
trying to deliver strategic impact and
so that takes a variet of different
forms um and we
usually it's whatever makes the most
sense with and for a given portfolio
company so um one thing I'll be I want
to be clear about is we don't actually
we deliver signal and kind of insights
in both directions but we're very clear
about sh uh sharing information we do
not share information without express
permission of our startups with
Microsoft so we actually operate what
I'll call pseudo independently we are
Microsoft Venture arm but we have our
own investment process we have our own
investment committee we make our own
decisions um we're very grateful and
thankful and you know fortunate to have
support from the you know our senior
leadership who's been very supportive of
M12 but we do make our own decisions and
we don't necessarily cross-pollinate or
or share any information back with
Microsoft again without the express
permission of our portfolio companies or
the Stars we talk to um it's an
important distinction because I think
you know some not every CVC runs that
way and so uh we do back to the
Strategic impact question we try always
pre and post investment to look for ways
that we can add value to our portfolio
companies right so it may not surprise
you to learn that people take our money
uh in the large part because of who our
LP is not in spite of uh and so they're
looking for ways to you know either
partner with Microsoft or get exposure
to our partner customer ecosystem and so
we actually have an entire portfolio
development team stacked against this
objective I they're like my superpower
previous gig I didn't have a team that
was dedicated to kind of portfolio
success we do have that at M12 we're
very fortunate to have that and so they
look they help the investing side which
I'm on the investing side to find ways
to accelerate outcomes for our portfolio
companies and those you know it can be
product Partnerships recently we just
announced something with inworld where
they're one of our portfolio companies
they're doing a really deep uh
partnership with Xbox and the gaming
side um so that that was a long uh a lot
of effort went into making that real but
um type face is another one we did
recently in the AI space um so we're you
know they're generative AI company
helping Enterprises use AI for their
marketing and content generation and so
we're work we're finding interesting
ways to work with these companies and
then connect them to the right folks uh
both within Microsoft directly as well
as a broader ecosystem so both
dimensions matter let talk yeah let's
talk a couple of success stories maybe
kind of the examples will will prove the
point um what's like an example of you
guys make an investment in a company you
and you are able to bring them into
Microsoft and you're like man that
wouldn't have happened or that company
wouldn't be nearly as successful as it
is today without being brought inside of
Microsoft uh yeah I think in world is a
great example right so the one we just
announced recently but that was an
investment that we made we then
introduced them to the gaming team um
number of conversations uh ensued and a
lot of work on both you know both the
M12 side as well as the Microsoft and
Xbox teams ultimately what that led to
was in so inworld is a an AI driven it's
a generative AI company they focus on
like non-playing characters and games
and so think of this as like
enabling an Infinite combination of
choose your own Adventures within a game
right you can uh every time you interact
with a game you can have a new
experience because there's AI brains
essentially powering these NPCs in the
games um to uh Power essentially
creative gameplay like side quests like
you know to power dialogue that is
contextually relevant and so in world
and Xbox have this now deeper product
partnership that wouldn't have come
about had it not been for the M12
investment and for the work that our
portfolio development and our investing
teams did alongside inside the Xbox
teams kind of embed their technology
into some of these uh into the platform
so that's one example um I think Noble
AI is another one we're we're doing a
lot of interesting things in like
Material Science development so
Microsoft uh Quantum Azure Quantum
elements our Quantum Computing
initiative and Noble have partnered um
they're very uh very complimentary
Technologies uh Noble is helping
companies like do new chemical
formulations instead of running physical
experiments which take a lot of time and
are costly and you know you can only do
a set number of physical experiments in
a certain amount of time you can now run
AI powered simulations to do you know
thousands of these for a fraction of the
cost so those are two examples of things
were you know kind of better together
now those are examples where you guys
made an investment you bring them inside
of Microsoft there's more value that's
accreting uh to uh these startups how
many of these startups is the end goal
for them or for Microsoft is Microsoft
to acquire the business versus actually
the success story ends up being the
businesses successful outside of
Microsoft Microsoft happen to be a
shareholder and kind of you know get
some sort of benefit uh in terms of
either partnering or being a user or
whatever but it's not actually to go and
acquire those businesses yeah it's a
good question we do not um set out in
M12 to find companies for acquisition
right we're not hunting for acquisition
targets we are a dedicated Venture fund
and we are really trying to do you know
true Venture investing in the sense we
invest in early stage seed through
series B let's call it companies that
are doing transformative things in
technology and part of that is to bring
signal and insight from the ma from
generally what's happening in the market
back to Microsoft not in an
individualized fashion because I
mentioned like the firewall around
information but more like where is the
market headed what technologies are
emerging what should we maybe be paying
attention to and we're trying to see
kind of see around corners or see into
the future right to a certain extent to
figure out where the technology
landscape is headed and so that's really
one of the you know information and
signal is like that's one of the ways we
we bring that back in the M12 side and
then of course direct investment in
companies right and finding meaningful
ways to work with them and we learn
things each party learns things through
that and so um we don't go out hunting
you know we have a very capable and and
corporative team and we have a good
relationship with them uh and they'll
send us deals that are you know true
Venture deals um and we'll you know also
funnel uh I guess help folks connect
folks within Microsoft to the relevant
teams whether it's business development
or corev or whom
um as needed now there's another group
of people that you seem to be able to
help these startups with so you can
bring Microsoft you can bring Capital
but also sometimes you can bring
Microsoft's customers or Microsoft's
Partners so it's kind of like a step
away from the company talk a little bit
AB how that works yeah uh so we have a
number of there's a whole range of
different U resources available and and
oftentimes M12 can help act as the front
door to Microsoft and the different
resources that we have for startups uh
we we work really closely with the
Microsoft for startups team for example
they you know have a whole Suite of
capabilities that they roll out for
start early stage startups Azure credits
access to a wide variety of uh internal
resources including sometimes AI
assistants they actually run our our AI
co-innovation Labs we have a number of
these around the globe including in San
Francisco and a bunch of other places um
we just opened the sf1 recently um the
uh and those are like hand on keyboard
like engineering help to optimize and
Test new things like real uh you know
building with AI and they also run a
program called Pegasus which is an
invite only coell program for really
high prom or I guess very promising
startups or ones that are highly aligned
to kind of our own business objectives
and so we will actually provide coell
assistance um where Microsoft sellers
can um I guess go in and coell alongside
these early stage startups and get them
access to our customer customer and
partner ecosystem so we've done this
with and for a number of companies and
it really meaningfully accelerates their
trajectory right gets them in front of a
large number of Enterprise and other
customers um in some cases there's also
product Integrations that at where it
makes sense and so that that can really
uh you know move the needle for a lot of
these companies to to be able to co-sell
they can also U be on the Microsoft
Marketplace so a number of our both M12
portfolio companies and just general
startups can put in offerings on our
Market Marketplace and those can be then
um uh companies Microsoft customers can
then take advantage of those in some
case also use that as credits to their
Cloud commitments so there are way a
wide range of ways we can accelerate
outcomes on the go to market side um we
have a very capable sales team and
they've been certainly a force
multiplier for a lot of the startups we
were with yeah now this isn't the first
time that you've done corporate Venture
Capital you were previously at visa and
um I think if I went around and I asked
a bunch of people across the industry
like hey who's done this well as Corp
Venture Capital firm Visa is one of the
organizations they'd point to and say
hey those guys seem to have figured it
out talk a little bit about lessons you
learned at visa and then things that
maybe you're able to bring to M12 and
and help Implement and say hey look
these are ways that we can be really
successful here today's episode is
brought to you by trust and will I've
gone through a number of different
changes in my life over the last few
years I got married I had a kid and I
had to start thinking about how could I
ensure that my wife and my child would
be okay if anything ever happened to me
that's where trust wills and estate
planning I'm into play now most people
what they do is they get introduced to a
friend an uncle or someone in their
local community it tends to be someone
who's really expensive a lawyer an
accountant or somebody who does Estate
Planning and they just simply are using
a one- siiz fits-all template and just
telling you pay me thousands of dollars
and I'll use the same thing for you as
the guy down the street but that's not
what trust and will does they have a
trusted online estate planning product
that starts as low as
$159 which allows you to now protect
your legacy from the comfort of your own
home home leverage their excellent
customer support available via phone
email or chat they have thousands of
five-star reviews and a rating of
excellent on trust pilot it takes most
people 20 to 30 minutes to complete
their estate plan with trust and will
and not only that but if you go to trust
and will.com pomp you'll get 10% off
plus you'll get free shipping of all
your estate planning documents so go to
trust and will.com Pomp and make sure
you get an estate plan in place whether
it's for you or one of your loved ones
having a trust Andor a will can
literally be the difference between
someone being taken care of and someone
not go check them out today at trustand
will.com pomp yeah as you as you pointed
out I helped uh start what is now Visa
Ventures so we had some um great great
support from the top I think that's key
um we were very fortunate to enjoy that
at M12 as well but we had a CEO at the
time at Visa who really leaned in and
wanted us to do more with the technology
ecosystem so we were engaging with
everyone from Apple and Microsoft and
Google all the way down to early stage
startups which was actually the world I
had come from prior to joining Visa most
of my career has actually been spent on
the operating side building companies
and so uh helped stand up Visa Ventures
and did a number of investments in early
stage companies everything from uh
stripe uh chain Marquetta a number of
other uh now high flying companies they
were emergent companies at the time um
and interestingly we were actually
structured you know when I was running
it very similarly to how M12 is built um
and I I think you know there are
probably as many flavors of corporate
venture capital is there are
corporations that do it uh I I really
feel strongly about um you know not
requiring any unnatural acts from the
startups that you work with we don't do
that M12 either we try to do only things
that are organic or like you know
additive mutually beneficial um and then
finding ways to genuinely help I think
actually my opinion you know corporate
VC can often be maligned you know like
some sometimes there there are many
things that have been said about CBC I
won't repeat all of them um but I think
actually right now is a great time and
and you know folks like visa and and
certainly M12 are like ideally
positioned to be able to meaningfully
add value to the startups you know the
macro headwinds are real uh we see this
all the time and I think the the ability
you know the the joke in VC is like oh
let me know how I can how it can help
right well we're actually being helpful
like in a Quant quantifiable way right
like we're meaning Yul um you know
changing outcomes with and for our
startups and so that's I think the best
world and I think the other thing is
startups and Enterprises don't always
speak the same language and so if you
can find ways to connect sort of the
strengths of a startup the speed the
agility the creativity with the
resources of an incumbent right the
distribution Capital uh access and if
you can actually find ways to
constructively marry the two I I I've
long believed that magic can happen and
we were fortunate to do some of that at
visa and I think we're doing that at M12
as well so I I feel very strongly about
kind of the the opportunity if you
really you know I think uh if you really
do it well and and uh and set it up the
right way magic can happen what are the
downsides or maybe the challenges with
having usually one LP it's a corporation
there's kind of this like impact or
signal component along with making money
or what have you seen there in terms of
just things that maybe other Venture
Capital firms don't have to hand
that you guys do that maybe either slow
things down make it more difficult or or
potentially could just change things
yeah it's a good question in that you
know a lot of people compare the sort of
the financial VC like oh we don't have
to manage any corporate stakeholder we
don't have to like you know uh ask
permission to do a deal etc thankfully
at M12 we don't have to ask permission
either we actually have our own
investment committee so like things get
a little bit more a lot more streamlined
there um and the governance is you know
set up in a constructive way um
definitely you know again it varies by
by corporate VC and so if you're a
startup looking to take money I would
say you know just understand how
whatever Corporation you're talking to
or whatever CBC you're talking to how
they're structured what their deal
process looks like we're very
transparent with Founders in terms of
like how what it looks like on our end
like what are the state what are the the
the things we need to get through um
it's pretty streamlined for the most
part actually uh partly because of the
way we're we've set up our governance
structure um and you know people talk a
lot about like oh you have to like deal
with your corporate LP like to me
actually a benefit right like this is we
we were just talking about it like
having a relationship with internal
stakeholders at Microsoft allows us to
do a lot more for our companies right if
we didn't have those relationships we
wouldn't be able to open those doors and
I think the flip side is you know
Financial VCS I don't as a as a CVC I
don't have have to raise a new fund
every three years right and go out to
LPS like a lot of startups don't realize
like VCS actually are beholden to their
LPS right they're they have bosses so to
speak right that they need they need to
manage uh they have to deliver fund
returns they have to manage a whole set
of stakeholders which is non-trivial so
I don't have to do any of that
necessarily but in return what I am
doing is engaging my my leadership team
uh engaging key stakeholders with across
Microsoft and that all acrs to the
benefit of our portfolio at the end of
the day um and so you know it's just
there's extra work to do on both sides I
think it's just the nature of the work
and I I feel very good about kind of the
the end product that comes out of the
engagement that we have with our with
our parent parent LP that makes a ton of
sense let's talk about artificial
intelligence um there's a lot going on
there's a lot of capital flight flying
around there's a lot of startups that
are getting started where are you guys
most excited about or where do you think
kind of value is going to acrew and
there's really big opportunities for
startups and for Venture capitals that
are funding
them yeah so one thing I'll say is M12
actually has been investing in AI well
before this latest hpe cycle I know it's
like the hot thing to do these days and
certainly we're very focused on AI uh
now again continue or still U but we've
actually been an AI investor so to speak
for a long time and have a have a pretty
strong portfolio um to your point like
there's a lot of really interesting
stuff happening in in the space we're
paying very closely attention everything
up and down the stack right from the the
enablement layers the developer tools
all the way through the application
layer um I'm very focused personally on
what is real and like how what is
driving business value uh at M12 we
really only invest in B2B companies um
we don't really any do any directed
consumer plays and so we're focused on
B2B primarily software and so the way we
see AI I mean certainly it's it's
transforming everything I think Ai and
software inevitably just merge right and
to say in in short order it won't make
much more sense to say you're an AI
investor than it say than it is to say I
invest in electricity it's like okay
great to what end right like what's the
application um that being said there are
a lot of like core enablement
technologies that are emerging and we're
obviously you know both investing in and
paying very close attention to to
everything that's happening I think the
application layer so far what we're
seeing is that a lot of the value
creation and kind of the differential
between like the cost of inference for
example and the ability of to capture
value at the application layer is
there's a pretty big spread there right
so you see you know like for example
image generation companies right A lot
of these folks are making a large amount
of money
uh even though their inference costs are
very very low and so they're able to
like capture a lot of that spread and a
lot of that value um it'll be
interesting to see how long those things
stick around and and do they have
durability to them or are they just like
early movers that that have a a a lead
right now but that lead might shrink
over time or as Things become
commodified um I'm really looking for
Enterprise applications I think what we
what we really want to see and I think
what really needs to happen for AI uh to
have a long lasting meaningful impact is
we need to take this from you know the
bubble of Technology Centers like
Silicon Valley and make sure that Main
Street Main Street and you know the rest
of the world really understands and sees
the benefit and so those are the things
that I'm looking for is like how does AI
actually move the needle in terms of
business impact or like things that you
know normal people can understand and
see now there's a cohort of people who
are scared about Ai and all the AI
safety stuff they think we should pause
stop Etc Microsoft doesn't seem to be in
that bucket given the investing open AI
kind of all that stuff um but then
there's another kind of very far extreme
of just like accelerate without thinking
at all about downsides Etc how do you
balance these two things between like
let's go build and let's go you know
actually create value um along with
people who you know seem to have at
least genuine concerns about uh the
ramifications some of the
technology yeah I understand why people
might be apprehensive at the same time I
think if you look through the history of
Technology there have always been these
factions of people that are like oh no
like this new technology electricity or
whatever is dangerous it's like yes you
can electrocute yourself if you don't
use it the right way but it like it's
unquestionably that it you know moves
the world forward in meaningful ways um
Microsoft's been very I think vocal
about its position on responsible AI
building things responsibly and and
deploying in a way that is um you know
accounts for uh takes a lot of you know
different things into account so I won't
repeat all the the the stuff we've said
publicly but I mean it's all out there
publicly available and I think we do
think about AI is like a great
technology it's going to move the world
forward in meaningful ways we're already
starting to see that I'm really excited
about future waves of innovation powered
by an AI and what you know what net new
experiences that we can't even conceive
of yet today um might still come down
the pike um but that has to be done in a
way that obviously balances that with
you know you know you got to think about
bias you have to think about responsible
uses of AI um th those are meaningful
right and like we're as an Enterprise
company we're very focused on delivering
things that our our customers and our
stakeholders care about right they want
AI used in a responsible way that is
defensible and understandable by their
own businesses right Microsoft's been I
think had a leadership position in this
in terms of indemnifying a lot of our
customers around uses of microsof
technologies that involve AI um so we
obviously take a leadership position
there um I you know I mean where this
goes is anybody anybody's guess I think
it's actually very exciting and so I'm
not on the on the Doom side of things
but I think with every new technology
there are unforeseen you know
implications and it's just our our job
to think about those things
thoughtfully now there's also uh maybe a
debate between Google Microsoft and
other large companies they have tons of
data they have tons of distribution they
have tons of advantages in the market AI
is going to reinforce those advantages
and they're going to capture all of the
value versus Hey Joe Blow and his
startup or um you know some person who's
spinning out of one of these big
companies can go start a company to try
to disrupt and value is going to acre
there what's the balance or how are you
all looking at those two
things it's really it's a fascinating
question to me and I think it's one that
continues to evolve one of the things
this is the one of the fastest
technology adoption curves that I've
seen in my investing career and other my
career in startups so I'm old enough
have seen a few Cycles now um but enough
enough data points to know that like
this is pretty impressive the speed at
which both startups and incumbents are
leaning into this I think we're seeing
both part both ends of the spectrum
really like uh eagerly Embrace this new
technology I think certainly you know
folks with large data sets and uh
unique in particular unique and
proprietary data probably stand a gain
or or be able to do some really
interesting things with AI given and the
importance of data in this technology at
the same time you know I've been
investing and or building SAS for a long
time and I think the same things that
have always been true are still true
today in that you need something that's
differentiated you need a wedge you need
to deliver a unique value proposition
and I think there will still be
opportunity for startups to find wedges
to find points of differentiation that
are not being addressed by incumbents to
find new approach es of doing things and
actually the part I'm even most excited
about is net new like AI native
experiences that I don't think we've
really seen like great like canonical
examples of this yet but with every
platform shift you have companies that
are built that just weren't possible
before that platform arrived right Uber
unquestionably would not have been
possible at the scale and Su level of
success without mobile phones right and
the internet um I mean they were giving
out they were literally giving every
driver uh a a cell phone an iPhone um to
seed the market right and that would
never have been possible prior to that
and so I think we're going to see
similar types of companies be built that
are like AI native um that we haven't by
definition haven't been invented yet um
but to your back to your question I
think there are opportunities for both
ends right like clearly Enterprises are
leaning into this um but they want to
know what's real I think startups
there's definitely going to be uh wedges
and plenty of opportunity on the startup
side which is you know why I'm very
excited to invest
now ai has a software component and a
hardware component Hardware seems to be
getting more and more attention uh
Microsoft got a pretty big cloud
business uh seems to uh have these um
you know uh I'll call them uh fre
compute uh in a variety of different
ways that uh is being handed out some of
times it's just handed out to
accelerators other types of startups uh
sometimes it is being handed out in
exchange for Capital as an investment
from let's say Microsoft with the open
AI case how do you all think about the
compute resources of Microsoft and your
ability to leverage that to wind deals
maybe from an investment standpoint or
or anything
else yeah I mean every gpus is the thing
that's not everyone's mind right
everyone wants more of it uh more
compute please um look I I
uh I think you know I think this
bottleneck is probably a somewhat of a
short-term problem for the overall
landscape that's my my hunch I think you
know the the level of demand and
adoption probably surprised a lot of
people uh you know going back if you
think about a year ago and chat GPT was
First Unleashed to the world um and so I
think we're the hardware manufacturers
are catching up there you know there
obviously a lot of innovation happening
in that in that space um micro M12 is
actually invested in a company dmatrix
which is really interesting doing
interesting things on the hardware side
improving efficiency um obviously
Microsoft talked has talked about its
own uh work in that space and then on
the GPU side we're actually for M12 and
Microsoft for startups in particular
we're trying to make access we're we
actually announced access to some gpus
um for really high high potential and
promising EI companies um to help train
workloads and uh so we're initially
rolling that out for M12 portfolio
companies as well as y combinator the
hope is to expand that uh to a much
broader audience and make that available
to for really high potential AI
companies because we really want to
support the market as best we can um and
and Builders who are building
transformative things using AI uh want
to help seed that and accelerate it how
do you think about uh portfolio
construction and specifically when you
have a single LP who you know has the
proverbial like unlimited money uh how
do you guys think about not um maybe
folling following the same footsteps as
other very large players in the market
who have thrown hundreds of millions or
billions of dollars at companies that
maybe weren't ready for it what is kind
of the the discipline or like how do you
kind of think through okay if we have
unlimited money to give to people you
know kind of theoretically how much do
we actually give to a seed or series a
type
business I wish uh I wish that we had
unlimited money I loved when I knew you
were gonna say that I'm gonna take that
back to my CFO and see how well that
goes over uh yeah no we definitely do
not have unlimited Capital uh it would
be nice if we did but um I think this is
what I was alluding to at the beginning
right like the financial strategic
impact we it's very clear we are uh
evalua on financial metrics as well as
the Strategic piece and so you know
we're here to make money at the end of
the day um and so we have to be
disciplined and I actually think you
know not to Pat ourselves on the back
but I think we've actually been pretty
pretty uh disciplined in our deployment
of capital um there are a lot of deals
getting done there done out there in at
some of which are prices that I don't
quite understand uh I I can't quite make
the deal math work for in my head um but
uh we've been try to be very disciplined
and and really invest in companies that
we believe in that we think have
commercial viability and have an
opportunity you know I think there's a
lot of money chasing chasing a bunch of
deals it's it's a very challenging time
uh to be an investor frankly I mean it's
not not easy right now uh being a VC and
figuring out where to deploy Capital
intelligently and so I think in some
cases you might see a lot of money
chasing shiny objects and potentially
you know buing up those prices um for
our purposes we are trying to be very
responsible um you know we we get
measured on this and so it matters a
great deal right so I I wish we had
unlimited capital and just like the
blank check uh not the case so we we're
we think about a lot um in terms of also
you know the macro like SAS multiples in
particular right like AI aside um it's
just gotten a beating in the in the
public markets and I think that's
translated to the private markets as
well right I mean we're the median right
s like forward ARR multiple uh for SAS I
think is somewhere around like 6X um
which is like where it was like 10 years
ago you know we're gone are the free
money days so uh including including our
own
fund not that we ever thankfully we ever
we never really got wrapped up in that
which is actually really nice because
that we don't have the hangover from
that as a fund but um we've been pretty
disciplined along the way trying to stay
that way Le let's talk Bitcoin and
cryptocurrencies I know at Visa uh you
were very integral in a number of kind
of crypto initiatives Investments uh uh
kind of strategic things um what about
Microsoft is that an area that you guys
are looking at from M12 or uh are you
just there's so much opportunity in the
AI stuff right now that that's not
really a
focus this episode is brought to you by
cal.com what do I have in common with
Chad Hurley from YouTube Toby from
Shopify and Alexis from 776 and the
co-founder of Reddit we all use cal.com
instead of Cly and we are all early
investors as well cal.com is leading the
charge of scheduling Platforms in the
open source sphere offering you the
chance to harness the efficiency
previously reserved for leite
corporations and Tech gurus if you like
to have your calendar organized and be
able to have an efficient exchange when
scheduling but you love all of the
benefits of open- source technology then
cal.com is for you they are transforming
sophisticated calendar management into
an accessible tool for all via a
userfriendly interface you can customize
it and you can make your calendar work
for you use code pomp for $500 off when
you set up your team with cal.com today
again go to cal.com
cal.com and use code pomp to get $500
off when you sign up cal.com an open
source tool that allows you to take back
control of your calendar be efficient
when scheduling and make sure that no
one can steal your time uh a little bit
of both I mean we obviously Ai and you
know know B2B software are like first
and foremost for us I mean they're
really front and center um we've done
number of investments in the kind of web
3 crypto space mostly again we only do
really B2B Investments and so we focused
on primarily on infrastructure uh on the
web 3 side um space and time actually is
a portfol company of ours I think you
know in I've long I've had a
long-standing thesis personally that the
way that Bitcoin or cryptocurrency or
any of these things really gets to scale
and massive adoption is going to be some
version of a mashup with trafi and you
know crypto now that may be you know
antithetical to some people and like the
all you know who are all in on crypto
but really if you want main stream to
Main Street to adopt this it's going to
have to be in some you know regulated
way or in some way where like there's a
there's an integration with trafi and so
I think you know on the infrastructure
side space and time is I think you're
really interesting doing some
interesting stuff around blockchain and
helping connect uh more traditional
databases with like blockchain enabled
ones um and then just generally speaking
I think you know we look at kind of
infrastructure or like plays that are um
moving the ball forward in a meaningful
way but again it's really very B2B
focused so not really on the consumer or
coin end now when you look at um some of
these B2B companies I I would say that
uh there's been a rise of like hard tech
uh you know Cutting Edge Innovation Etc
but there's still massive market for
just traditional B2B hey I can make the
calendar better I can make Excel better
I can make you know whatever the product
are um does it ever play into the
investment decisions when you talk about
the Strategic component like Microsoft
Excel is pretty popular there are now
companies who want to disrupt Microsoft
Excel does that increase or decrease the
odds that you all may want to invest
where it is something that is actually
coming after like a Microsoft product
itself or a category where you guys are
dominant and so you know some people
would argue like hey you actually may
not want to participate because you hope
it doesn't disrupt you know the
mothership uh on the other hand some
people may say no it's every great you
know company wants to disrupt themselves
and so let's go invest how have you guys
thought about that so far yeah yeah it's
so I actually love companies that are
like just either deep industry like have
a Founder with like deep wonky industry
expertise or like doing like you know
nothing related to AI I love AI don't
get me wrong but uh I also love the the
more traditional you know SAS companies
that you were alluding to in the
beginning um I I think some of the those
are some of the more interesting
companies still I in fact I'm talking to
one right now and like the oil and gas
base right and like they nothing AI
related but uh it's very interesting in
terms of what they're doing like the
alternative is you know humans moving
physical buttons and doing physical
things like and like there's no software
involved right like so there are
industries that haven't even fully
realized or even partially realized uh
the advantages that software or the
cloud can bring and so there's massive
upside I mean if you're look at like
Financial Services believe it or not
like about I think it's like 50 50ish
55% of of of financial institutions have
even like a cloud presence and like
something like less than 3% um are
spending more than 25% of their it
Budget on the cloud like think about
that that's in financial services where
you'd think like oh it's all in the
cloud already like no no like it's still
just tiny uh you know just making
inroads still a huge upside potentially
um back to your other question around
like uh competitive Dynamics I think
actually the canonical example for me in
like SAS is like can you own a workflow
or create software that just places
Excel right Excel is a massively it's
like a Swiss army knife on steroids it's
amazing um I'm I'm a huge Excel junkie
uh but if you can replace it with
something that's more specialized and
like a software application for an
industry or a particular use case that
you where you can like maybe co-opt or
or create the workflow like that's a
that's a great indicator for me like
where you can actually and I've seen
some of these companies recently and
just historically like that's that's a
great sign uh on the competitive stuff
we try not to invest in like obviously
competitive things because back to where
we we were talking about uh earlier in
the conversation we try to find ways to
add value right and if you're doing
something that is like obviously
competitive to something that we're
doing first party there's probably a
limit to what I'm going to be able to do
for you and so you know we I'm not
trying to create uh you know uh I'm
trying to create productive
relationships with our startups and so
finding ways to like accelerate their
outcomes or add value and so I think we
look for more complimentary things and
actually you'd be surprised there are a
lot more complimentary I think
opportunities than there are competitive
ones um it might look at first blush to
be competitive like oh you're you're
threatening whatever but a lot of times
there are really interesting ways to
work together and actually I actually
think Microsoft has done this better
than most companies in its history there
are a lot of Partners where you know we
have this coopertition Dynamic where
they're selling something that is you
know it looks or maybe even is somewhat
competitive to our first-party stuff but
we're still partnering right and we
actually find ways to collaborate so
this has been a longstanding dynamic
within Microsoft and I think we actually
do it better than most companies I've
seen um but from the M12 side you know
we're always looking for ways to like do
find the 1 plus 1 equals 3 to the extent
we
can what is the thing that you do on a
daily or weekly basis that would
surprise people the most right like I
think most people understand kind of
startup Founders and their day-to-day
activities Venture Capital as well you
do some of that you talk to Founders you
also kind of manage the mothership right
like what would surprise people about
your your daily or weekly uh kind of
habits or or schedule
I love your I love this question
um you know VC I think in VC you see the
deals that get announced you see all the
you know the the the stuff that makes
the headlines I think what you don't see
is like the the discipline and the I
don't want to call it a grind because I
enjoy it but it is a little bit of a you
know there's this like the repeatable
like consistent like grind to a certain
extent in terms of like sourcing deals
talking to Founders like doing diligence
like all the the work that goes into uh
one deal that gets announced or gets
headlines and you know other VCS have
talked about this but we talk to many
many more companies than we ult
ultimately invest in and so that's all
like a huge amount of effort that
happens below the surface that is not
particularly visible um but you know
informs our thesis driven investing it
informs you know us knowing what good
looks like and then ultimately when we
find a deal that we really have
conviction on and really want to partner
with a Founder on that that all that
then you know is worth it because you
you able to really uh have a meaningful
relationship there with the company but
I think that's something that would
maybe surprise people is like the amount
of work that goes in that is just
invisible to the outside world uh in
terms of sourcing and constantly
evaluating and like the the deal funnel
right it's actually not dissimilar from
from the sales in terms of like top of
funnel and like deals that make it
through the through different stages
ultimately to to an
investment before I let you go let's
talk uh Twitter SLX uh you are uh like
the fourth or fifth person who's come on
the podcast that has uh first name
handle so you just have at Peter um
which means uh you either been around or
you somehow finagled your way into it I
I'm just old I've just been I've just
been around that long yeah all right
that's good that that that's better than
the other answer um but one of the
things that was fascinating to me is you
just tweet out you're like hey if anyone
wants to talk to Microsoft's Venture arm
DM
uh I can only imagine what happens after
you do that tell us like like is it
thousands of DMS it's a good problem
Anthony yeah I mean but do you find
deals from that like like what Happ
absolutely so I look I uh I'm not I have
derived so much personal and
professional value from Twitter SLX that
I hope it continues on forever I there's
a it's going through a rough patch right
now I think but like I just love that
Network and I've actually made really
strong like IRL you know like in real
life connections with people um and yeah
I mean like when I when I tweeted that
recently I was like yeah you know if
you're building an AI might be a good
time to talk to us uh it's always a good
time to talk to M12 I'll just add uh
would love to any anyone my DMs are open
um rip my DMs um but uh so feel free to
reach out I mean look I think deals good
deals can come from everywhere um and
you know back to your last question of
like what what is the part that people
don't see is like me responding to DMS
late at night uh you know looking
through pitch dexs like all that stuff
it's a good problem to have it's a
problem I love having uh so feel free to
send us your your startups but um yeah
no
that's I just loved it when I saw you do
it I was like man what a move right it
was right after the open Ai and you
tweeted you're like yeah now might be a
good time and uh and I could see from
the comments I knew people were dming
you so I was like oh that guy's DMS were
gonna be destroyed for the next cou days
I I'll take it I'll take it I would much
rather that than the alternative no one
no one caring that that I exist so
follow give follow Peter on Twitter and
send me a DM if you're if you're
building in AI amazing uh well now that
we know where to find you where can be a
find more about M12 and kind of
understand really what you guys are are
looking to invest in yes uh
m12.9 so you can read more about the
other investors um and also our kind of
a thesis area so I I uh uh I don't want
to say who it is because I don't want to
embarrass some but people have listened
to the podcast for a long time will know
uh who I'm talking about uh we had a
gentleman come On's he's older very
successful entrepreneur built a company
that you would know and at the end I
asked him how can people find you and
before I could like stop him he not only
said his name his uh social handles and
stuff he also said his email and his
phone number and so we cut out the phone
number after after uh you know post
production but uh but the email like you
sure you want me to leave that in he's
like yeah don't worry about it and then
he literally later was like I should not
have given out my email he doesn't
understand the power of the pop right
yeah no no no it was just he he is
somebody who a lot of people want to
talk to and he's not like really on the
internet so the only way to communicate
with them was through this email well I
can give you my PO box but let's not go
there all right Peter thank you so much
for doing this uh if anyone has not
checked out M12 highly suggest doing it
you guys have a great track record and
obviously been deploying a lot of
capital into uh artificial intelligence
many other areas uh so you I highly
suggest they come and check you guys out
and we'll definitely do this again in
the future love it Anthony thank you so
much for having me it's really been a
pleasure